[Music]
what can you tell us about season two
well first season two they're showing a
lot of size of the other characters and
from their point of views and kind of
the situations that they were going
through in their personal life and that
mom so I think it's really cool that
they're gonna be very dynamic it's gotta
be hard when the first season of your
show makes such an impact and like does
it raise the bar how are you guys gonna
make things new or different that season
- yeah the bar is definitely high but
you know I believe in the team in 13
reasons why riding the team and the
producers they they have a you know
creative way of making things happen and
I would say season two is gonna be just
as interesting as season one so I'm just
happy to be a part of it in a couple
words how would you describe it plot
twists what does that mean
it's a secret you have to tune in to see
it's got to be amazing though it's gonna
be amazing is it I think a lot of people
are gonna be like like one of those
this just says in season 1 they're doing
in season 2 they just bring so many
different emotions and situations on you
that it's just has you going on a roller
coaster I know it's been such a passion
project for Selena Gomez how involved
has she been with the second season for
the second season you know I think she's
just more so a part of the background
things and as far as wrapping it up but
we have different producers and
directors and everyone we worked with
and I think we had a lovely team and
it's just so good for me that I get to
work with so many different people and
learn different things what have you
learned from her from people on the set
working on this show you know Selena
Gomez is like you have to remember
everybody's human and you know everyone
has something they're going through and
different sides of things and people
relate to the show because there are so
many situations that others can relate
to whether you're high on the platform
low on the platform it's like we all
come together because at the end of the
day we're all human and so we all go
through bad situation with the situation
so more than anything it's important to
be there and support your people in your
[Music]